because as I speak volume two of your
report is being laid before Parliament
we know that you intend to make some
remarks to introduce that volume of your
report
but sir before you do so we will observe
a minute silence
to remember those who were killed in the
arena attack
and that minute will start now
so that concludes the minute silence
thank you
we have started with a minute silence
to remind ourselves if we needed
reminding
that 22 special and much-loved
individuals died
as a result of the murderous attack by
Salman abedi on the 22nd of May 2017.
Volume 2 of my report includes a summary
of the tributes which we heard at the
beginning of the inquiry for each of
those who died
the summary does not do justice to that
very moving evidence
but I hope it does to some extent
capture the individual qualities of each
of them
the majority of volume 2 deals with what
happened after the explosion during the
rescue operation carried out by the
Emergency Services
in the course of the evidence of what
happened after the explosion
I saw CCTV evidence
and video from body-worn cameras as a
city room
that showed clearly the appalling
aftermath of the explosion
it showed those who had died within
seconds of the explosion
it showed victims with appalling
injuries
I have considered post-mortem evidence
and expert evidence which confirmed that
those who died did so as a result of
injuries caused by a bomb exploding
there can be no question on the evidence
that those who died died as a result of
the actions of Salman abedi
those actions also cause the severe
injuries suffered by many people
who attended the concert or were waiting
to collect children who had attended
those who have listened to the evidence
will not be surprised that I am highly
critical of many aspects of the rescue
operation
those criticisms must not overshadow our
admiration
for the courage of those who went into
the city room without any hesitation to
help the dying and the injured
there were members of the public
there were people who were working at
the arena on the 22nd of May
there were British transport police
officers greater Manchester police
officers travel safe officers and
paramedics
who went into the city room to help
others without regard for their own
safety
while their courage should be recognized
by me and I do
what is most important at this time is
that I identify what went wrong
and recommend changes to ensure that the
same mistakes are not made again
that is what has guided my Approach
throughout this inquiry
during the evidence the suggestion was
made
that the greater Manchester fire and
rescue service in particular are the
Northwest Ambulance Service to a lesser
extent were risk averse
while there is a case for saying that
some of the decisions made by some
commanders were unduly cautious because
of concerns they felt about the risks
inherent in responding to a major
emergency
there was no evidence that individual
firefighters or members of the ambulance
service were other than ready and
willing to carry out their job of
protecting and saving life
the evidence of the firefighters was on
the night of the attack they were angry
that they had not been in the city room
helping to rescue the injured
I did not find there was evidence to
support any suggestion that the
commanders making the decisions were
risk-averse for their own safety
it is one thing to take a risk on your
own behalf
it is another to send people under your
control into a situation where they
might be injured
having said that many things did go
badly wrong and it has been the job of
this inquiry to identify them
work out if possible why they went wrong
and make recommendations to ensure if
possible that they don't happen again
the criticism that I have made are
principally directed at organizations
and there were significant failings by a
number of organizations in preparation
and training for an emergency such as
this and in their actions on the night
of the attack
I have also criticized some individuals
for decisions that they took on the
night
some may think that to criticize
individuals
who were faced with an extremely
difficult situation is Harsh
but we rely on people in command
positions to make the right decisions
when faced with a complex emergency
none of them intended to make the wrong
decision
some had not had sufficient instruction
or training
and others were doing their best to
balance the need to help those who were
injured with ensuring that people under
their command were not put in a position
which carried excessive risk
it have been my job to identify when and
how things went wrong
so when incorrect decisions have been
made however understandable I have had
to identify them
I have not looked for scapegoats
and everyone who I have criticized has
had the opportunity to respond to those
criticisms and I have taken their
observations into account in my report
to the extent that I accepted them
many of the things that went wrong on
the 22nd of May have gone wrong before
either in genuine emergencies or in
exercises designed to test out the
Emergency Services procedures
the best example of this is the failure
of Jessup
The Joint Emergency Services
interoperability program
on the night of the 22nd of May
it failed almost completely
Jessup was introduced in response to the
recommendations of Lady Hallett after
the inquest she held into the death
caused by the 7-7 bombings
Jessup is designed to ensure that any
rescue attempt involving more than one
of the Emergency Services is coordinated
so that all follow the same plan and
share information so that well-informed
decisions can be taken
had Jesse worked on the 26th of May
things could and should have been very
different
there would have been a joint assessment
of risk taken by all the Emergency
Services
and the result of that should have been
that there would have been more
paramedics in the city room
using their skills to triage and where
necessary using their life-saving skills
to assist those who couldn't wait to be
removed from the city room before they
received treatment
firefighter would have arrived on the
scene to use their considerable skills
to ensure an organized and safe removal
of the injured to the station entrance
where they could receive assessment and
treatment pending a rapid transfer to
hospital
instead
we heard heartbreaking evidence
of the injured and The Rescuers who were
in the city room
hearing the Sirens of ambulances
knowing paramedics were close by
expecting their imminent arrival
only for them not to arrive in the sort
of numbers which were needed
had firefighters got to the city room as
soon as they could have done
they would have removed the injured
using proper equipment which would have
been safe and quick
instead the injured had to be removed on
railings and pieces of cardboard which
were uncomfortable unsafe painfully
and inevitably this meant that it took
longer for each patient to be removed
this is not the first time that Jesse
has failed both in real emergencies and
in exercises
with the help of core participants I
have set out a number of recommendations
to try and ensure that it works in the
future
those are only some of the large number
of recommendations which I hope will be
accepted but more importantly actioned
by those who are in a position to make
the necessary changes
one of the other areas covered in the
report is the care Gap
that is the inevitable gap between an
event such as this bomb explosion
happening
and the arrival of people trained to
give Expert Medical help
to try and reduce that Gap
what we need to ensure is that there are
suitable people on site at places such
as the arena who are able to give
emergency life-saving assistance which
may result in people surviving who
otherwise would not if they had to wait
for the arrival of medical professionals
this could be included as part of the
protect Duty
but we will need to see what the
government proposes
can I repeat my encouragement to the
government to consider bringing in
legislation imposing a protect Duty on
companies that operate large places of
entertainment who cater for large
audiences like the arena as soon as
possible rather than trying to include
that as part of a comprehensive protect
you to
I am not to be understood by that to be
discouraging a protect Duty for smaller
venues which I support
it is just that I can see no reason why
the duty for larger venues should not be
completed quickly
as I think has been accepted police
officers firefighters and those who are
likely to be first on the scene should
also have those necessary life-saving
skills
finally but not least important members
of the public who are unlucky enough to
find themselves at the aftermath of a
disaster and choose to remain and help
should have the opportunity to get
training to enable them to do something
which may save a life
members of the public made an enormous
contribution on the night of the 22nd of
May
but it would have been even greater
if they had had the training to deal
with the sort of injuries that they were
faced with
I have made recommendations on all these
topics although implementation in some
cases may already be taking place
we also heard evidence
about the different systems used in
other countries to try and ensure the
best possible chance of saving lives
some of those countries use different
procedures to try and ensure that the
best possible medical assistance is got
to the injured quickly and they are
removed to hospital as soon as possible
it may not be possible to replicate
those systems in this country
but we should consider radical
alternatives to ensure the best possible
outcomes
I have made recommendations designed to
ensure that these alternatives are
considered
and that everything can that can
reasonably done to fill the care Gap is
done
we had a hearing quite a long time ago
about the steps that I needed to take in
order to monitor my recommendations as I
am determined to do
having carefully considered those
submissions we have been in discussion
with the home office to decide on the
best way to achieve this
I believe that in principle it is
accepted that there is a strong argument
for some of the recommendations to be
monitored
agreement has not yet been reached as to
the best mechanism for achieving this
I have had a meeting with the Home
Secretary to try and bring this matter
to his feedy conclusion and that will be
followed up by a further meeting
I believe that I have reached the
correct conclusions about what went
wrong
I've had this systems of many very
clever and hard-working people
to all of whom I'm extremely grateful
I also hope
that this inquiry will make a difference
and the things that went wrong on the
22nd of May will never be repeated
this is a hope which is shared by the
Home Secretary
and I hope that we can work together to
achieve that aim
I am confident that all the Rescue
Services are also determined that this
should happen